en las afueras de Soledad las columnas
de humo delatan la intensidad de los
combates hace varios meses ucranianos y
rusos luchan por esta ciudad en el don
Baz ahora el grupo de milicias Wagner
asegura tener la ciudad Bajo su control
las autoridades rusas sin embargo
señalan que la batalla por soledad
continúa las unidades aerotransportadas
bloquearon soledad desde la parte norte
y sur de la Ciudad las fuerzas aéreas
rusas están atacando bastiones enemigos
escuadrones de asalto están luchando por
la ciudad
unas horas antes
elogió la resistencia de las tropas
ucranianas a pesar de las dificultades
encontradas en este frente
La batalla por el don más continúa y
aunque los ocupantes han concentrado
ahora sus mayores esfuerzos en Soledad
el resultado de esta difícil y
prolongada batalla será la liberación de
todo nuestro Don
Gracias a todos los combatientes de
Soledad que resisten nuevos y aún más
violentos asaltos de Los Invasores
para los rusos conquistar soledad y su
antigua mina de sal significa acceder a
sus túneles bajo la línea del frente
La ciudad está tan solo unos kilómetros
de basmut una zona de dudosa importancia
estratégica pero que los rusos
consideran un símbolo
desde bakmut los habitantes pueden oír
el sonido de los combates muchos llevan
varios meses viviendo allí en la
indigencia
duermo con la misma ropa que ya durante
el día
no hemos lavado En 4 meses
pronto todo se congelará aquí
las fuerzas ucranianas tendrían defensas
estables alrededor de bamut y por ahora
controlarían varias rutas de suministro